[Musique]
bonsoir à tous début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 27 mai voici les
titres de ce journal le verdict des
élections européennes dans le
département la liste elle la république
en marche modem arrive en tête devant
europe ecologie les verts et le
rassemblement national 3 yvelinois
devienne député européen mathilde andrew
et mounir satouri françois-xavier
bellamy analyses et réactions à suivre
une première marche pour le climat à
saint quentin en yvelines samedi elle a
réuni près de 300 personnes dans les
rues de l'agglomération c'était à
l'invitation de 48 associations locales
au lendemain de la grève mondial des
jeunes et puis retour sur les résultats
sportifs du week end au vélodrome
nationale les championnats de france de
gymnastique par équipes et une montée
pour trappe en football c'est à la fin
de cette édition
à suivre également tout à l'heure
quelles stratégies pour les zones de
commercial de maurepas et coignières
éléments de réponse avec mon invité
grigori gary astier mais tout de suite
j'accueille un premier invité sur ce
plateau c'est stéphane minson bonsoir ou
pensera vous êtes professeur de droit
public à l'université versailles saint
quentin et sciences po saint germain on
va commenter a des goûts ses résultats à
des européennes également nicolas landry
bonsoir bonsoir grégory de la rédaction
de tv 78 dans un instant les résultats
de ce scrutin dans les yvelines et vous
nous livrera également quelques
réactions un mot d'abord sur les
résultats au niveau national c'est le
rassemblement national qui arrive en
tête de ces élections européennes est la
liste conduite par jordan bardella a
recueilli 23,3 pour cent des voix c'est
presque un point de plus par rapport à
la candidature renaissance de nathalie
l'oiseau qui regroupe la république en
marche et le modem 22,4 pour son aile et
de mouvements en tête auront
respectivement 22 et 21 sièges au
parlement européen
troisième de ce scrutin une surprise
avec le score de 13 5% obtenue par
europe ecologie les verts menée par
yannick jadot suivent à l'est
républicain de l'illinois françoise
françois-xavier bellamy la france
insoumise et également la liste place
publique parti socialiste les autres
candidatures dont debout la france
génération lui dei ou encore le pcf
n'obtiennent aucun siège au parlement de
bruxelles
strasbourg stéphane mention le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche largement en tête on peut y
trouver un point de stabilité après les
élections présidentielles de 2010 est
finalement deux forces qui sont
largement en tête devant les autres un
point de stabilité alors que provisoire
si vous voulez je crois que ça confirme
j'ai trop entendu dire soir ça y est la
vie politique française et bipolariser
de nouveau mais pas comme elle l'était
avant les présidentielles et avant les
européennes je n'irai pas jusque là
simplement les choses se décantent après
la lente décomposition du paysage
politique français jusqu'en 2017 la
recomposition est à l'oeuvre
elle n'est pas achevé si vous
additionnez les deux les scores obtenus
par les deux listes on n'est pas à 50%
il est aux environs de 45 45 % du corps
électoral pour un scrutin d'une nature
tout de même assez particulière donc il
faut pas tirer des conclusions hâtives
mais les choses commencent à se dessiner
peu à peu on voit quand même que et
s'étale avantages de chacun des deux
chacun des deux d'ailleurs de marine le
pen et deux aides emmanuel macron que
les choses tente tout de même à se
polariser autour de c2c de force oui et
on en avait parlé ensemble sur ce
plateau derrière on a encore
l'impression d'un certain chamboule-tout
avec qui s'est produit aux
présidentielles
lr qui fait son plus mauvais score
depuis qui fait son plus mauvais score
sur l'histoire sur une élection
nationale 8,2 pour cent le ps qui est à
6 4%
on parlait peut-être d'un retour du
clivage droite gauche sur cette élection
finalement ça ne s'est pas produit non
ça ne s'est pas produit est d'ailleurs à
l'image plus ou moins mais de ce qui
s'est passé dans pas mal de détails
européen où je ne dis pas que le clivage
droite gauche et est jouée à disparaître
totalement est partout mais en tout cas
là on l'a clairement senti dépassé est
assez fier j si vous voulez une espèce
de clivage un peu du 20e siècle et sur
cette élection une surprise la troisième
place d'europe écologie les verts alors
comment on peut l'expliquer on entendait
dans les différentes réactions hier sur
les antennes que finalement les
écologistes sont ceux qui travaillaient
le mieux
au parlement ils connaissent leur
dossier est ce qu'il y ait aussi ça
aussi un motif d' explication
l'inquiétude des jeunes face à l'urgence
climatique qui peuvent aussi expliquer
ce second score d'europe écologie les
verts
je pense que les arguments que vous que
vous que vous évoquez sont assez justes
il est de notoriété publique que les
écologistes sont se consacre de manière
très sérieuse à leur mandat européen
lorsque celui ci leur est confiée les
statistiques le montrent les écologie
sont très présents font beaucoup de
propositions et de manière assez assez
constructive et cela s'est su et et tant
mieux c'est une prime aux élus qui
vraiment travail je ne dis pas que les
élus ne travaille pas mais en tout cas
parmi les représentants que la france
envoie à bruxelles
certains ont d'ailleurs été réélu il y
aurait beaucoup à dire et puis on sait
que c'est aussi le vote de la jeunesse
alors le vote de la jeunesse au regard
d'une prise de conscience d'une
inquiétude sans doute mais d'une très
forte prise de conscience des enjeux
climatiques
on dit toujours que le corps électoral
préfèrent l'original à la copie
tous les partis toutes les formations
s'affiche comme étant plus ou moins
écologistes là on s'est tourné vers vers
l'original et j'ajoute que le scrutin
européen est traditionnellement
favorable aux écologistes souvenez vous
en 2009 cohn bendit avait fait 16 % 2014
9 c'était plutôt un mauvais score là on
retrouve un étiage qui est un très bon
score mais ya eu mieux alors l'autre
surprise de ces européennes c'est la
participation l'annoncé bassalah été
finalement supérieur à ce qui avait été
annoncé
le taux de participation en france
s'établit à 51% une tendance similaire à
celle de 1994 qui étaient autour de 52%
dans les yvelines s'est également du
jamais vu depuis 25 ans participation
pour ces élections européennes est de 53
92 % presque huit points de plus par
rapport au scrutin en 2014
comment on peut l'expliquer cette forte
participation est ce que les françaises
sont saisis du sujet européen où on peut
on peut expliquer finalement que c'est
un vote de sanction sur la politique d'
emmanuel macron non ça je ne je ne le
crois pas je pense
je pense que le brésil a joué quand même
un rôle extrêmement important c'est la
première fois en 40 ans qu au moment
d'une d'un scrutin européen
une telle configuration se déroule est
évidemment l'image renvoyée par le brr
exit a sans doute ce ne sont que des
hypothèses mais a sans doute justifié
motiver une partie assez forte de
l'électorat qui s'est dit finalement
voilà on peut pas on ne peut pas laisser
les choses se faire
il ya plutôt eu un
en france d'ailleurs comme dans le reste
de l'europe presque partout c'est un
cetain une adhésion à ces fortes
finalement les forces anti européennes
sont très minoritaires seront très
minoritaire au parlement européen
contrairement à ce qu'on attendait cette
vague populiste qui étaient annoncés ne
s'est pas produite
il ya peut-être eu ça aussi que dans
l'est où titre des motivations de
l'électorat mais je crois que le brésil
vraiment à jouer un rôle d'épouvantail
assez assez fort enseignement plus
locale à retenir de ces élections 3
yvelinois font leur entrée au parlement
européen il y en avait aucun lors de la
précédente mandature depuis 2014
françois-xavier bellamy en tant que tête
de liste
l air était quasi certain de siéger à
bruxelles et strasbourg les choses
étaient moins sûr pour la conseillère
régionale 1 mathilde andraud et en 22e
position sur la liste rassemblement
national elle devient finalement
eurodéputés el mounir satouri également
conseiller régional et élu d'opposition
au mur au profit du bon score de sa
formation europe ecologie les verts pour
devenir député européen alors justement
comment les yvelinois ont-ils voté pour
ce scrutin des européennes nicolas
landry de la rédaction de tv 68 pour y
répond alors quel est l'enseignement a
attiré sur sur ce département des
yvelines nicolas bien grégory
contrairement au niveau national c'est
une victoire de la république en marche
dans le département des yvelines la
liste renaissance soutenu par le modem a
obtenu près de 30% des voix 15 points
devant europe ecologie les verts le
parti du président de la république
s'impose dans plusieurs des plus grandes
communes des yvelines
comme vous le voyez à
saint-germain-en-laye avec plus de 39%
des voix
écoutez les réactions de la député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines nadia
et du référent la république en marche
du département aujourd'hui on a montré
que nous étions aussi qu'il fallait
compter avec nous dans dans la sphère
politique que nous étions là bien
présent que nous avions des électeurs
aussi qui nous était fidèle et je crois
que le département des yvelines
ad oc enseignements à tirer de ces
élections c'est un échec patent pour la
droite traditionnelle conduite par
bellamy localement dans
yvelines on voit très bien la lassitude
de l'électorat pour le parti
historiquement présents ici la
république c'est surtout un message
important que les polissons politique
pris par les publicains depuis quelques
temps ne sont pas du tout en adéquation
avec les attentes des citoyens les
yvelines est ce qu'il ya des surprises
nicolas pour ce scrutin au niveau des
yvelines comme au niveau national la
surprise elle vient d'europe écologie
les verts la liste de yannick jadot
arrive à la seconde position dans le
département avec 14 72% des voix
elle double quasiment son score réalisé
lors des dernières élections européennes
en 2014 avec 7 66% des suffrages et les
événements dont un représentant a comme
vous l'avez dit l'écologiste mounir
satouri la sensibilité de nos
concitoyens sur la question de la
critique est logique
la sortie des pesticides est présent
dans l'esprit des clients
et puis je crois que les chinois en ont
à la fois rares du règne sans partage de
la droite ait l'air et le score on et
démonstrations et que jusqu'à la
dynamique de la république en marche si
elle a marché pendant l'initiative je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de déception à
noter pour la gauche le score de benoît
hamon a à trac il arrive en tête sur la
commune avec près de 26 % des votants
devant la liste du rassemblement
national à quinze points 64% cesson
c'est un meilleur score qu'au niveau
national pour lui et pour le
rassemblement national qui arrive en
tête au niveau français qu'en est-il
dans les yvelines
la liste de jordan bardella arrive en
troisième position le parti de marine le
pen récolte 14 36% des suffrages et
poursuit son implantation malgré tout
dans le nord du département autour de
mantes-la-ville la zone périurbaine le
rassemblement national arrive en tête
dans sept villes récoltant plus de 26%
des voix pour rappel c'est la seule
commune francilienne dirigée par une
majorité est reine le mouvement
souverainiste fait entrer comme vous
l'avez dit aussi dans les titres unis
been oiseaux parlement européen mathilde
andraud et et on écoute le chili positif
c'est le fait qu'au tour de
mantes-la-ville nos scores sont bons
termes et en tête
donc je pense que en l'acquérant quand
on porte un drapeau national à un
endroit
il fait des petits je pense que filmer
fut la meilleure preuve qu'elle nous
essayer c'est l'adopter
la déroute et là aussi c'est une
surprise nicolas il vient du parti des
républicains
vous le savez grigori les yvelines c'est
un bastion historique de la droite
indivis noah porter la liste des
républicains pour ce scrutin françois
xavier bellamine aussi adjoint au maire
de versailles
pourtant il arrive en quatrième position
même si le résultat est plus élevé qu'au
niveau national avec plus de 12% des
votants dans sa commune il termine
derrière la république en marche et le
modem avec 27,66 % des voix contre 29%
c'est une surprise pour les républicains
yvelinois écouter la sénatrice sophie
primas et le président de saint quentin
en yvelines jean michel fourgous et a13
est une option d'âge donnée à trèbes le
fait même il a évidemment une surprise
de mauvaises surprises mais plutôt une
surprise pour moi c'est pas dans ces
moments là qu'il faut voilà et c'est son
avenir en fichant reprendre sa
respiration qui faussent poser un petit
peu qu'il faut beaucoup consulté tout ce
qui est dans notre parti maintenant à
l'extérieur du parc et ont une voix qui
compte pour la droite républicaine
moi je conserve la conviction que on a
une nécessité ou si les trois fois le
chemin d'avoir un parti républicain
entre le rassemblement national en
marche il faut du parler vrai une des
élus il faut créer de la confiance il
faut rassembler les gens mais mais plus
que d'aller d'aller exploser tout le
monde éclate et la france comme elle
l'est aujourd'hui elle est et je les
trouve très divisée il faut il faut
créer la confiance voilà crée la
confiance c'est pas cela c'est vraiment
leur parler vrai aux gens tenir compte
de leurs différences
à noter aussi la réaction par communiqué
de presse du président de la fédération
les républicains des yvelines pierre
bédier
ils dénoncent selon lui le duel
construit par le président de la
république pour créer un duel face au
rassemblement national et appelle
ensuite à l'unité de ses partenaires
centristes pour réunir un parti de
centre et de droite stéphane mention
comment vous expliquez vous cet échec du
parti des républicains notamment dans
les yvelines parce que comme je le dis
au début c'est un département
profondément ancrée à droite un c'est un
désastre et il n'y avait pas de raison
que les yvelines soit à l'abri de ce
désastre national
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit les yvelines
qui sont une terre traditionnellement
très ancré dans la droite traditionnelle
de droite parlementaire la droite de
gouvernement
on voit que le front national se
consolide dans le nord du département
ce qui est ce qui est très étonnant
c'est enfin pu même à versailles on voit
voit que les républicains ne sont ne
sont même pas en tête mais ça qu'est ce
que vous venez ça s'éteint c'est un
désastre qui qui on voyait arriver on
sait que à peu près 20 à 30% des
électeurs les républicains au plan
national sont plutôt partis vers la
république en marche
on sait qu une part à peu près
équivalente c'est plus variable se
dirige plutôt vers le rassemblement
national
la voix est extrêmement étroite et quand
j'entends wauquiez et les éléments de
langage de communication des
républicains depuis hier signaler que
tout est de la faute de marine le pen
d'un côté emmanuel macron de l'autre
peut-être aussi que ces gens se se
regardent eux mêmes ce duel macron le
pen
il est à l'avantagé de chacun des deux
je crois qu'il était parfaitement
légitime
chacun avait une vision de l'europe
extrêmement clair extrêmement
antagonistes par rapport à l'autre donc
ya pas ici il ya un peu de montage
politique mais je crois que ce ce face à
face était parfaitement légitime
les républicains va écouter on verra
mais à 8 les choses s'annoncent
extrêmement compliqué merci à stéphane
dans son professeur de droit public à
lui vécu merci à nicolas d'andry pour
tous ces éléments sur les élections
européennes dont l'actualité du week-end
il y avait aussi une marche pour le
climat plusieurs villes de france ont
participé y ont participé samedi à saint
quentin en yvelines c'était une première
le reportage de mélanie poker patrick
jacques de dixmude une lettre pour les
élus de l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines
on a mis une adresse internet où les
élus peuvent nous répondait même nous
habite et s'ils le souhaitent
posté à l'occasion de la première marche
pour le climat à saint quentin en
yvelines
elle était organisée par un collectif de
48 associations locales 60 70 % des
actions se font au niveau local donc
c'est au niveau local qu'il faut agir en
premier
voilà donc c'est très important que les
saint quentinois se mobilisent les
yvelinois la démarche des yvelines
cette marche était prévue au lendemain
de la deuxième grève mondial des jeunes
partis de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines avec près de 300 manifestants
selon les organisateurs d'une marche
sais pas c'est parce qu'il va ramasser
les déchets ou directement en fait c'est
plus quelque chose qui va sensibiliser
les gens qui vous ya passé quelque chose
qui prend de l'importance
et c'est grâce avec ce genre
d'évènements pompeux comment dire que
recruter les gens pour faire toutes les
autres actions
il faut aussi préserver tout ce qui a
comme comme verdure encore autour de
nous comme culture cci nos pc un peu une
opération survie maintenant on a des
enfants on aimerait qui grandit dans une
sur une belle planète est la prochaine
marche devrait avoir lieu à versailles à
l'occasion du sommet de l'onu le 23
septembre et un nouvel invité avec moi
en plateau c'est grégory jarry astier
bonsoir bonsoir à vous êtes maire les
républicains de maurepas également
vice-présidente saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de la stratégie
commerciale alors l'agglomération à a
lancé une grande étude urbaine pour
redynamiser la zone commerciale maurepas
coignières les deux communes ont en
commun cette zone commerciale qui
comprend paris ouest le forum gibet les
portes de chevreuse juste pour présenter
déjà cette zone elle est stratégique
pour ces deux communes à coignières et
aimant paye pour le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines très stratégique
puisque vous le savez saint quentin en
yvelines c'est le premier pôle
commercial des yvelines et que on a deux
grands pôles majeurs le premier étant
celui de plaisir et l'éclair et le
deuxième étant celui de maurepas et de
coignières avec les zones que vous venez
de citer
c'est à peu près 500 millions de chiffre
d'affaires 4300 emplois donc ce qui
n'est pas rien en effet donc c'est
stratégique pour le territoire
et pourquoi il convient aujourd'hui de
repenser cette zone quels sont les
problèmes qui sont présentés
vous sur cette zone alors en tant que
vice-président j'avais souhaité qu'on
réponde un appel à projets de l'état sur
repenser la périphérie commerciale avec
justement des zones commerciales qui
sont en désuétude et qui ont besoin
d'être dynamisée
et il se trouve que vous savez en tant
que maire j'ai lancé la construction
d'un éco quartier s'appelle écoquartier
des 40 arpents dans la zone d'activités
paris-ouest donc je fais du
renouvellement urbain où on va un
construire du logement et des
équipements publics des parcs urbains et
on a été retenu aussi grâce à cette
volonté par l'état qui nous aident
financièrement avec un cabinet d'étude à
repenser globalement les trois zones
dont vous venez de parler c'est un
concours national qui a été lancé par le
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
exactement un concours national dont il
y avait 24 dossiers qui avaient été
déposés six lauréats
donc on travaille en groupe avec les six
lauréats notamment la métropole de
marseille aix en provence celle de
limoges également
donc c'est très constructif et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit qu'on est sur
des zones d'activités notamment paris
ouest qui est à deux tiers sur maurepas
et un tiers sur coignières qu'en plus de
40 ans et qui ont besoin d'être repensé
en lien avec le forum du gibet et les
portes de chevreuse et aujourd'hui quels
sont les objectifs que vous affichez
qu'elle comment mettre aussi en oeuvre
ce projet alors on a des objectifs quand
même qu'ils sont assez ambitieux puisque
je le rappelle c'est 16 hectares qui
sont concernés
251 magasin alors après son nez sur le
périmètre opérationnel ses 151 magasins
de prêt mais on a un objectif qui est
déjà de refaire la ville sur la ville
c'est à dire de la repenser sur
elle-même et d'aborder j'allais dire des
éléments d'aménagement qui nous
permettent de nous diriger vers
l'innovation environnementale et durable
c'est-à-dire de d'imaginer les zones
d'activités du futur et aujourd'hui on
se rend compte qu'on est avec des
problématiques aussi qu'ils sont 10 à la
mobilité les zones commerciales ne
communiquent pas entre elles on a des
identités qui sont totalement
différentes
pourquoi pas nous peut-être rassembler
sous un même nom ce ces pôles
commerciaux mais ça ça viendra dans un
autre temps donc on est accompagné par
un cabinet d'études qui aujourd'hui
s'axe sur des enquêtes terrain donc
aujourd'hui on est des enquêtes terrain
auprès des clients et consommateurs mais
aussi des directeurs d'ems saigne et on
aura une autre partie qui sera sur la
concertation publique ça il ya
différents temps de concertation
exactement le premier arrive
sur le vide greniers de maurepas le 2
juin celui de quoi le 9 juin exactement
et le 8 juin on sera sur les au préau
sur le centre commercial d'auchan à
paris ouest
il ya également une enquête en ligne qui
est prévu jusqu'au 17 juin exactement
médine vote
donc j'invite évidemment tous ceux qui
nous regardent à y répondre tous ceux
qui sont concernés
là c'est vraiment une honte demande la
vie justement des consommateurs qui vont
sur le lieu d'achat pour demander leur
avis qu'est ce qu'il pense de cette zone
commerciale qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
modifier les avantages comme les
faiblesses pour nous aider ensuite
l'année prochaine à calibrer des
scénarios opérationnels pour après se
lancer dans les 15 années qui viennent
dans d'une restructuration assez lourde
très rapidement je voulais également
avoir votre réponse sur cette autre
sujet qui la piscine intercommunale qui
doit voir le jour pour votre commune et
celle de d'elancourt
elle se rend en lieu et place de
l'ancien centre aquatique est fermé
depuis quatre ans et les travaux de
démolition ont démarré est-ce qu'on est
dans les temps on est dans les temps
aujourd'hui malgré les dires au courant
qu'on lancer mon opposition et
heureusement il est rond et est même
condamné par la justice du fait de
d'avoir lancé des recours complètement
abusif et aujourd'hui voilà on voit
enfin la lumière j'allais dire puisque
la déconstruction a commencé du bâtiment
tout est fait dans les règles et qu'une
entreprise qui est bien habilité et
ensuite en parallèle on mène les
négociations avec les candidats qui ont
déjà été retenues pour le
concessionnaire pour le concessionnaire
voilà donc
on va bientôt arriver dans la période de
négociation dans quelques jours pour
ensuite une sélection d'ici à l'hiver et
une reconstruction de l'équipement au
premier semestre 2020 pour une livraison
comme prévu en 2021 les autres travaux
du moment à maurepas 2 principalement
c'est la réhabilitation du centre-ville
et l'extension du groupe scolaire de
l'avion à vendredi la conseillère
régionale anne cabrié venu représenter
la présidente valérie pécresse sur place
au programme visite des deux chantiers
subventionné en partie par l'île de
france dans le cadre du contrat
d'aménagement régional la collectivité a
accordé 1 million d'euros de subventions
à maurepas on écoute à ce propos
anne cabrié c'est au micro de marie line
yapi chez nous c'est des projets que
doit porter la région pour permettre aux
collectivités d'aller au bout de leur
projet parce que vous savez très bien
qu'aujourd'hui et les dotations aux wc
et que la région est subventionné à
hauteur du plafond maximum là pour le
cas à millions d'euros en permettant
d'accéder aux collectivités et à
maurepas
mais d'aller au bout de ses projets il
faut qu'on accompagne les maires et
c'est sur des dispositifs très divers
grégory guéri c'est pourquoi ces travaux
sont primordiales pour la ville de
maurepas alors déjà je remercie
évidemment valérie pécresse président de
la région ile de france aisne cabrières
d'avoir porté les dossiers se c'est vrai
que c'est une vraie aide pour la
collectivité et pourquoi ils sont
primordiaux alors que primordiaux déjà
les col de la llose est en vérité quand
même d'un patrimoine qui était très
abîmé qui n'avait pas été rénovée depuis
des années et la priorité ce sont les
écoles et les queue de l'avion était la
plus abîmée la plus vétuste on avait des
fuites un peu partout et donc là on a un
vrai projet de créer un groupe scolaire
en additionnant l'école maternelle et
l'école élémentaire
et là on a gardé finement le squelette
et on change tout on est vraiment sur
une école j'allais dire du futur dans le
sens où on va revoir les salles de
motricité
on est sur le thème de l'origami ont une
démarche environnementale aussi assez
forte puisque en bakr et dessert aussi
dans les classes pour la démarche
développement durable pour les enfants
voilà on voit tous les locaux la salle
de restauration avec des plafonds
antibruit même de la musique pour
détendre
bref voilà
c'est important aussi pour nos enfants
de d'étudier dans de bonnes conditions
comme pour les enseignants et pour le
centre-ville aussi primordiale un centre
ville
héritée des années 80 qui avait été
renouvelé une seconde fois en dans les
années 80 il ya un manque de visibilité
pour les commerces de proximité
un manque d'accessibilité pour les
commerces et pour également les
habitants
également on va y refaire tous les
éclairages le mobilier le sol les flux
et les espaces verts
on va replanter des arbres bref voilà un
on se lance dans des aménagements qui
était utile pour les commerces de
proximité mais aussi pour retrouver un
cadre de vie j'avais dire plus
qualitatif de ce qu'il était auparavant
et c'était en effet une une vraie
priorité d'autant plus qu'avec
l'ensemble des subventions l'opération
finalement sur le centre-ville ne coûte
600 mille euros à la charge de nos
patients sur un million 3 quand même et
l'école de la llo 4 millions 7 elle ne
coûtera que deux millions six avec
l'ensemble des subventions qu'on aura et
la vente du terrain qui sera à côté de
la maternelle pour faire des petits
pavillons à côté merci à gregory
carigiet maire valérie publication va
également vice présidente à 2 saint
quentin en yvelines le sport c'est tout
de suite dans ce journal
[Musique]
la chronique sport comme tous les lundis
de michael et le mindoro et ses
résultats une fois n'est pas coutume
hickel on parle de gymnastique pour
commencer les championnats de france par
équipes et est organisé pendant trois
jours au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parmi les
mille cinq cents gymnastes présent les
des sportifs de la gemme elancourt
maurepas en concouru en division
nationale une après une après-midi de
compétitions intenses les gymnastes de
l'ag mais l'encours maurepas termine à
la 5e place et arrive à se maintenir
dans le championnat de division
nationale une
l'objectif du club avant le début de la
compétition
un super résultat également pour gmail
en cours maurepas qui a également
remporté une médaille de bronze en dn4
un classement qui n'était pas forcément
espérer un très beau week-end pour la
gemme également du football mickaël et
de la régionale 3 exactement trappe
recevez à les mureaux lors de l'ultime
journée de r3 en cas de victoire
associée à une défaite de boulogne
billancourt les trappistes pouvait être
champion
une source de motivation pour les
joueurs qui mènent rapidement un puis
deux puis 3 0 après une première période
spectaculaire ils s'imposeront
finalement sur le score de 4 buts à 1 et
sont champions de la division on écoute
les réactions on récupère cette première
place qu'on a occupé les trois quarts de
l'année ça fait vraiment plaisir tout le
mérite en revient aux joueurs au staff
aussi kim a un qui m'accompagne à la
direction qui m'a fait confiance cette
année est vraiment fier aussi de
terminer meilleure défense de la ligue
de paris sur la saison on encaissé 12
buts cc c'est énorme c'est c'est énorme
c'est vraiment peu et c'est une grosse
saison 0 5 buts par match c'est ce qui a
fait notre force soutient cette saison
très fier de temps tant d'années qu'on
recherchait ça le club
il est beaucoup d'investissement de
joueurs d'efforts de sueur de rigueur et
away très fier de faire pas vraiment
monter ce club moi l'équipe la régionale
de haut niveau attendu par les
trappistes depuis 35 ans imaginez
grégory pour réussir sa saison prochaine
le staff veut conserver son groupe en y
ajoutant de l'expérience avec un
objectif en tête bien sûr le maintien
merci michael plus d'actualité sportive
à suivre dans un instant dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport c'est la fin de ce
journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
ans